the old saying is you know like a house
of cards so that must mean fragile that
must mean imminent collapse I know that
a house of cards can be way more stable
than anyone thinks this harvard-educated
designer draws on his background in
architecture to build unbelievable
structures out of cards they can hold
bricks with stanley flowers and some are
dozens of stories tall I don't really
think there's a limit to how tall a
house of cards could be like the limit
is your ceiling and you know just having
enough cards my name is Brian Berg and
I'm a professional card stacker burger
career and card stacking started when he
was 8 years old he broke his first world
record when he was in high school in
since then he's broken several world
records often beating his own previous
record I know this will kind of sound
crazy but I actually don't even know how
many times I've done a Guinness project
so I know I've done the world's largest
house of cards twice tallest house of
cards in 12 hours once and then the
tallest house of cards I want to say I'm
I've officially went after a record I
think like I don't know six eight times
at least and the one where he built the
tallest house of cards in 12 hours it
was on top of a fully loaded washing
machine that was turned on and spinning
at a thousand revolutions per minute
guinness kind of worked hand in hand
with us to create a new record category
that was tallest house of cards in 12
hours with an asterisk on top of a
loaded spinning washing machine that's
not part of the category but you know
just had to make it even more impossible
of course I was like kind of terrified
that I would get a couple hours into it
and it would kind of start vibrating
anyway it's just nuts sometimes what I
have to do thing I always liked about
the cards was it wasn't figured out you
had to sort of invent your way through
it you had to make it work when birds
not chasing world records clients pay
him to build card structures for events
and commercials he's been stacking cards
professionally since 1994 but he started
building when he was just a little kid
card playing has always been a big
part of my mom's side of the family
while you know everyone was refilling
drinks you know taking a bathroom break
my grandfather would oftentimes you know
build a small house of cards with like
one deck and it would get two or three
or maybe four stories tall if it
collapse and he you know curse and then
the card plane would resume and so that
was my real introduction to card
stacking was my grandfather he did teach
me a few things but I really don't use
those techniques anymore everything else
that I do is a sort of series of happy
accidents that I've discovered along the
way I'll have a lot of people come up to
me and I'm working and they'll say you
should have been an architect and I'm
like well that's my real background Berg
does have a degree in architecture and a
master's in design from Harvard but by
the time he went to college he was
already an expert card house builder a
craft defined by trial and error and one
of the most critical discoveries he made
was that the typical pyramid shape won't
cut it all the engineers and architects
out there I'll tell you that the
triangle is the strongest shape and it
is but it kind of relies on ends being
fixed together or being forced to be
together
there's nothing forcing these anywhere
other than gravity to the ground like
you just saw so Berg relies on squares
and right angles instead the primary
technique is you know what I call the
grid the grid is you know you're setting
the cards at right angles at their
midpoints to create basically a bunch of
boxes for me like card stacking you know
the more I figure out about it the more
I'm able to do and the more I'm able to
do it just sets me up for the next
discovery there's the grid there's the
the column that came out of the grid
technique there's the wall that came out
of the column technique I would say that
the majority of things that I come up
with now are some sort of a tangent of a
tangent of a tangent of something else
that I already knew how to do at every
single project I sort of have a little
observation that makes me better or I'll
do something without even realizing it
and think oh that worked or oh that
looks cool
and I just kind of keep adding it to my
repertoire Burke recreated the Beijing
Olympic Village and cards in a Chinese
mall in 2008 for that I built the bird
nest stadium which was another thing
that I had no clue how I was gonna even
possibly do that but I'm like yeah sure
I'll do it you know I got thousands of
people standing there watching me
including my client like when I'm
starting it and it's not working it's
like falling over and I'm sitting there
thinking what am I gonna do but you know
that's the fun thing about it is you
just have to invent your way out of the
problem and keep moving bird built the
world's tallest card structure in 2007
it stood just a smidge over 26 feet tall
and for this one he tried something new
he built with the card standing
vertically instead of horizontally he
had never used that method to go that
tall when I built called latest version
of the tallest house of cards that was a
little bit intimidating because it was
probably three times taller than I had
ever used that technique before so I
just you know took a risk and went for
it so I really didn't know what would
happen it required over a thousand decks
of cards and took about a month to build
and it stood and it was surprisingly
strong so a thousand decks of cards you
know built to you know into the world's
tallest house of cards is you know
somewhere in the neighborhood of a
hundred and forty pounds which means
that no sneeze is gonna knock that over
it's actually gonna take a pretty big
force so I was using a leaf blower to
knock that house of cards down and the
leaf blower started smoking and quit
working during the implosion so I just
like you know threw the leaf blower down
and had to go after it with my hand so
you know card house defeats leaf blower
go figure
Burke sometimes uses three to four cards
instead of just one because adding
weight to the structure adds stability
it's just a lot more stable than they
think it is you know is it fragile yes
but is it gonna just fall down because
you you know threw a penny at it or
because you walk past it probably not
and a lot of that is just because how
many cards are involved you'll think
about how heavy a stack of
newspapers is or our stack of magazines
it's really heavy when you forget about
all of that mass and it's it's a it's
more of a brick house less of a card
house Bert used over 200,000 cards to
build the world's largest card structure
back in 2010 in this case it was
basically a massive replica of the
Venetian casino in Macau it was 4,000 x
45 days it's actually more than 45 days
of work because the last week of it
really didn't sleep and when he finished
he used a tried-and-true method to knock
it all down a giant fan Berger's built a
couple of things with glue when clients
asked him to but aside from these
exceptions Berg is a card stacking
purist I don't tape or glue the cards
bend them or fold them or modify them in
any way I think the thing that surprises
people is that gluing is actually just
insanely time intensive takes like a
hundred times longer than just letting
gravity line everything up for you when
Berg was given 10 hours to build
whatever he wanted he decided to try
something he had never built before for
this rocket you know when I got here I
didn't exactly know how I was gonna do
it I didn't exactly know how it would
turn out but I had an idea and I knew
that as I kind of started working
through it that I'd figure out what I
wanted to do
he started by making sure the conditions
were right there's always some sort of
climactic consideration is there a
subway outside you know down three
stories but another one is the humidity
so if it's too humid the cards will take
on all this water vapor because they're
made out of paper
and they'll want to kind of curl up
likewise if it's too dry they will do
the same thing they'll kind of start to
change shape Berg leaned on his
architectural background to build the
different elements of this rocket in
this case the main structural design was
a series of columns arranged around a
hollow Center he designed as he went
listening to his instincts like he
always does one big surprise on this
project was that I didn't finish
covering outside of the rocket because I
actually really liked the kind of lines
chasing down it and so I just left it
and you know I couldn't have built a
central post in the middle and you know
I could have built a sheer wall or two
inside to stabilize it but I didn't for
the sake of time and the cool thing
about not doing any of those things is
that it it created this totally Hollow
structure that looks really cool without
the skin on it so it's again happy
accidents here's the thing about Berg's
craft he can't move the things he builds
and are usually in public spaces so
almost everything he builds has to be
destroyed shortly after finishing a
question I get a lot is you know aren't
you heartbroken when you you know to
destroy one of your works and it's like
well honestly no because people love it
you know people aren't just drawn to
destruction they like to see stuff you
know collapse and fall you know it's
never a good scene I think but when it's
a house of cards it's just good clean
fun I know it can't stay up forever I
mean I can't take it home with me so
might as well have a good time knocking
it down and the other part of it is I
sort of treat each implosion as a little
bit of a
a test the sort of structural nerd in me
really likes seeing like what it can
take and then you know witnessing that I
go forward knowing that you know the
project that I'm working on next it's
just not gonna fall down randomly it
helps me understand the limits I'm
testing it and having a good time I'm
knocking it down because I kind of have
to and that almost more than anything
has given me guts and those guts he
developed meaning that he has no fear
when he stands on a ladder and finishes
these incredible architectural feats
you know when I'm up there putting the
last few cards on I'm not even remotely
worried about it collapsing out from
underneath me because I just know from
experience that it's just not going to
happen my track record of success with
cards is just because you know it's the
right mix of you know using what you
know and just the right amount of risk
and you know hope for the best